hey what's up this is the Bondi seas for
rocket League
video guess I'm doing a blue Keane
effects explosion you guys led rocket
League it's a good game really fun game
we had a lot of remote-control cars left
over from when we shot the mini-drones
video from last year and we're like you
know what do a rocket League video so
one thing you may have noticed in the
video is that we are playing the game on
our phones with a controller just right
there if you're wondering how it's
possible it's actually because Sony has
its new thing for called remote play
where you can actually stream your
PlayStation to your phone and sit there
and play on your phone in a remote
location from your PlayStation
so you're basically getting the ps4 in a
little mobile screen that you can play
anywhere you have Wi-Fi or data
connection just pretty cool so we've
been want to make a real life rocket
League video for awhile so I figured why
not have us doing remote play playing
rocket League and then we take it a step
further and we just play actual rocket
League right there using the same
controllers and everything now we're
kind of talking about different ways you
could pull off the effect of you know
cars jumping and flipping and all kind
of stuff I was thinking why not just go
the classic old-fashioned route of
puppetry I actually did a little test so
I wanted to see the effect at work made
it and put it on my Instagram of just a
little car driving around flying landing
on the wall and then jumping off oh if
you want to see it just go to follow at
neko dig it's kind of like from there
the expectations were that this video
would look pretty neat as long as we
went through and executed how we're
supposed to we had two sticks actually
there two arrows we had two arrows
without the tips that we gaff tape duct
tape sorry to the bottom of the car we
need to do it from the front or from the
side and the reason we use two sixes
that way we can rotate the car either
set there and ran along with the car and
two sticks so they can get Drive and
jump and flip and all that kind of stuff
and it try to be a mix of like hopping
it and letting it naturally tumble and
fall so we ended up having to do a lot
of takes over and over until I got the
motion just right especially when you're
actually try
hit the soccer ball yeah I did actually
try to hit the soccer ball in a couple
shots which worked which makes things
like way more real so then we had to
paint me out and do that Ren basically
motion track the footage using buzu
because we've made a point of shooting
in this alley because it's very simple
geometry means it's a flat wall and flat
ground this is very easy for render then
reproject a clean wall texture and a
clean ground texture back into the scene
Ren here of course has gotten really
good at projection mapping for doing
paint outs with a moving camera in space
basically giving you unlimited freedom
yeah it's pretty much my favorite effect
now yeah so that meant is that we didn't
have to be to lock down to the camera we
could move it you do crazy stuff if
something right there moving the car
like practically holding on to it if you
want to and you just remove the person
and suddenly everything looks really
strange and cool if you want to learn
exactly how I did this effect for this
video I have a tutorial link in the
description my case so the main concept
of what's called projection mapping or
camera mapping is you take an image and
you project it onto a surface for
example let's say you went and you got a
picture of a brick wall and then in
After Effects you built a plane you
could reproject that picture of a brick
wall onto that plane effectively
texturing that plane with rick texture
now in its alleyway what we need to do
to remove me was basically make a clean
background that was motion tracked with
the scene yes I mean like so for that
the final big shot where the cars like
flipping back to blocks the final goal
basically you would just project that
frame onto that geometry and then I
would just wrote a scope out Nikko from
the wall on the ground so that you would
have like what looks like this wall with
this big hole in it and when you make
enough of those little sections like
that you fill in all the gaps so
eventually you end up with this big
giant clean plate of the camera going
through the scene with nothing in it
then after that you rotoscope the car
back into the shot making it look like
the car is just naturally there moving
on its own like magic eye metal there
stop fighting me guys thank you Doug my
number one your
circumstance are you ever loved yeah cuz
that was that was another thing that was
on the drawing board was should we do
like an entirely CG video where all the
cars are CG and we're just like you know
in little cockpits and stuff trying to
hit the balls and ultimately that would
have just been like prohibitively
difficult to do yeah less impressive
honestly you know it's kind of strange
because you're right it is it's like you
get all the CG it's like the more CG
stuff you add the less impressive it
becomes well it's also into the magic
trick perspective you know it's the
effects are doing magic tricks
ideally good B effects are doing magic
tricks on film you know if something's a
CG rendered object and you can tell us a
CG rendered object then it's done it's
not a functional magic trick it's like I
can tell how you did it you use a
computer you generated that object
versus if you have a real element that
you filmed and it's composited into
other footage that's also real then it
gets really hard to tell how it was done
because everything's real and so it's
way better at tricking your brain and
it's way better at kind of triggering
that magic trip effect that good visual
effects can do by CG I mean like
rendered out in like 3ds max or Maya or
something like that when it's an actual
filmed car even it's from a different
shot where somebody's moving on sticks
it just looks so much more realistic and
that's one of the keys to getting cool
effects is knowing when to get real
elements as opposed to trying to build
them in 3d the video centers around us
playing rocket League in real life but
what about the rest of the video because
that's like 25 seconds to the video and
you can't just upload that so decided to
do kind of like a anime inspired just
constant like zoom pushes it's an
interesting pacing and it's an
interesting like vibe throughout the
videos just like go go go go until we
get to the fight so well
you're seeing my wagon so Ren is away
again it's a nice wagon actually really
nice wagon say their butts and many
shoots he stole my wagon the wagon
disappeared like a month ago Spencer
from unit six was using it to clear out
unit five of garbage left in the loading
dock and a homeless man took it I'm
gonna be the bigger man and not go steal
it back
I wanted to go take it back but then I
would have felt bad for taking a wagon
from a homeless man even though it was
my wagon
shoutout to Sony Mobile for hooking it
up thank you guys and I hope you guys
enjoyed the video there's a lot of fun
to make the effects were really cool
hopefully you've answered some of your
questions regarding the trickery that
we've pulled in this video and you can
check out us in another Samaniego video
one week from now that's right every
week we make one of these it's great